I got my ticket for the long way round I
think from the very first movie you
could tell that we all had chemistry as
a cast everyone was just joking around
and so much of that got in the movie we
knew that something special was
happening I don't think that any of us
really thought it was gonna turn into
what it turned into
when I'm gone when I'm gone we all get
along really really well
and it's so awesome hanging out with
them every day these are my friends for
life
it's very emotional because this is our
last film and these movies have been so
instrumental in our lives you ain't seen
nothing yet
in pitch perfect 3 you meet all of us in
different stages in our lives since the
last time you saw it
they've graduated college have spread
their wings that are attempting to fly a
fire Blair's delight with a shot of
white privilege hopefully not becoming
the failures we all expect them to be
you see us living our life trying to
figure out which direction we go and not
doing so well I quit my job you want
fine no I quit it's fine
reaction I would do anything to sing
what you guys again
Eddie's every year the USO puts on this
performance to support the troops in
Europe one last show together who is
with me hell yeah
we just think that we're gonna sing for
fun and very quickly realize that it's a
competition on the tour we've got three
bands you guys just sing other people's
songs right like a cover band they're
trying to intimidate us let's just do
two
is it weird that everybody is better at
the one thing that we do then then we
are at that thing all right ladies pick
up your test we're going to show him
that we are not a joke the other two
movies are about these band of misfits
and how we overcome obstacles and the
next one is about a family that we've
created man there's something about
these movies that can make anybody smile
or feel something
it's perfect really strikes a chord and
audiences hearts because everybody likes
a story about triumphs and about coming
together your real family doesn't hold
you back they lift you up this really is
the end of the Bellas as a group but
it's the beginning of the Bellas as a
family
my taco finish this
one last show together who was with me
hell yeah it's perfect strikes a chord
in audience's hearts because everybody
likes a good girl power story we love
empowering women whether it's each other
whether it's through directors and
producers being involved we're really
proud to have a female director on the
film and female writers and an
all-female cast either my friends for
life do this and to be promoting really
interesting fun stories for women for
pitch perfect 3 I was so excited that we
got Trish see cuz she's another really
strong female director it's been great
working with strong brave powerful smart
creative women through this whole
process the wheel firmly doesn't hold
you back they lift you up girl power is
for real now on pitch perfect let's talk
a finish this we love the messaging to
young girls about teamwork about
friendship and about what they can
aspire to in their own lives
we've never competed against bands that
actually have instruments so what's the
plan let's just do what we do I think
what I'm thinking every false yeah
the riff-off is going down today rip it
up today we're ripping it it's gonna get
pretty lit here to say the riffle this
time around is different
you guys just sing other people's songs
like karaoke Carrie oh that's so cute
we're not dealing with acapella on
acapella violence anymore we're dealing
with musicians on a tour that play
instruments so ready
but there's a new band called ever moist
who are very sexy and moisty they're led
by Ruby Rose fellow Australian yeah yeah
in calamity
this is serenity recipe and charity if I
joined your group I could be a B C team
then they settle up and they're actually
a real contraband in real life it's not
acting fulfilling
we're jammin they're really like
down-home salt-of-the-earth guys
everybody loves that right and then his
DJ dragon on some DJ Lanie yeah yeah who
are also just bringing it I find myself
smiling and like rocking out to them you
can tell they love what they do and
their energy is so infectious it's going
down turn up pitch
we like to keep it oral
is that where that everybody is better
at the one thing that we do then then we
are at that thing as far as mu-1 it
would depend on what proves you us they
just disqualify themselves by using
musical instruments
what does that we win guys we should go
I feel like nobody can ever really lose
a ripoff because it's just so amazing
anyway we won fellows are doing what
they do best quitting
here's the problem John the Bellas are
not as good as the other bands that is a
startling insight we're taking you on a
global tour with the fellas welcome to
Brad Sonny Audrey's dad has a connection
at the USO and she gets us on the USO
tour
worldwide now it's all to support the
troops welcome to Spain fellas so this
is the first base will we be going to
second base with you guys
that's a note from me so it's been very
heartwarming to work with the military
because they've been really been
generous to us from day one and they
weren't even real deeb USO tour takes us
to different parts of the world and on
crazy adventures why I like you Dan
dozens of examples spring to mind these
movies have always been friendship
movies but this one really grazes the
bar I love you
on the first day of pitch miss my true
love gave to me my kid got a spell a
family on a second day a pitch miss my
true looking eyes awesome nerd the third
hi drew
Sina
I love you awesome nerds my hello acha
people get rid of all the akka politics
welcome to akka initiation nights this
is like a thing now
they also gods have looked down on us
and they have given us a second chance
take the dramatics down a notch I think
we're gonna be awesome yeah that's not a
thing for such a disappointment
yeah first dev because you asked up
kitchens listen up Alka bowlers oh no
it's happening you're one of those a
cappella girls i'm one of those a
cappella boys and we're gonna have our
children we like to keep it strictly
oral oh this isn't just any college
party this is a cappella or anyway yeah
so get prepared to meet a lot of
sexually confused man know what I'm
doing here excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me pack up and leave it [ __ ]
hands innaka [ __ ] let's haka finish
this what's your name fat Amy
you call yourself fat Amy yes twig
[ __ ] like you didn't do it behind my
back I trust you will add your own
cardio no I don't hold me down for
cardio all right time to drop a smash
what I'm just gonna pump and dump
oh sorry my babes are all crazy I was
just jumping [ __ ] should never be
trapped I have a feeling that we should
kiss I sometimes have a feeling I
couldn't a crystal meth but then I think
mmm
better not yeah wrestled crocodiles and
dingoes simultaneously you guys are
gonna get pitch slaps so hard your man
boobs are gonna concave welcome to Spain
Bella's so this is the first base will
we be going to second base with you guys
hey that's a note from me
are you ready here you have to audition
for the Bellas I can't concentrate on
anything you're saying did you cover
your drop you know this sets women back
like 30 years ass work
I would be stoked to start them sorry I
don't say stoked I don't say something
us making choices I'm pretty cool you're
gonna like me
yikes I just wanted to check you out
before the worlds we're gonna kick your
ass just because you are making me very
sexually confused does not mean that you
are intimidating who are you nobody
literally nobody that was bad to Reggie
is it Reggie Rebecca that happens a lot
though you'd be surprised this dead air
between us it's a good sign Beca saying
[ __ ] what do you want to watch first
we do something else we could relive my
parents divorce visit a gynecologist
that's real Asus business in here the
whole time I'm just small I think we
should change it into feisty mouse Chris
Rock everybody you're really drunk right
now I don't think you're gonna remember
anything not shocked at all use Larry I
can see your toner through those jeans
that's my dick I love you awesome nerds
Becca what are you doing don't
if you cry a little cry don't make that
face I'm not doing it don't make that
face this is my regular face so on the
tour we've got three bands hello we're
the Bellas formerly a Barden University
and currently of life you guys are
seeing other people's songs right oh my
god um okay stop they just don't like
sharing the spotlight so they're trying
to intimidate us think about bacon what
is like a riff-off yes what is it a
riff-off is a little game that we like
to play let me start with a beat oh oh
go ladies
coming up so you go
in my 6po with my Bella
is that feedback so it's singing guys
still need that level check for vocals
Oh baby we're just getting started
I was fine in myself
they just swallowed by themselves by
using musical instruments because
done.we one guys who should go
we won fellas are doing what they do
best quitting here's the problem John
the Bellas are not as good as the other
bands that is a startling insight
how many ladies were going to show them
that we are not a joke
let's ought to finish this try to have
some dignity we don't do anything we
have dignity okay
what a beautiful everyone of them going
nowhere
you